[Music]
plastic waste as far as the eye can see
the plastic bank is a social project
that wants to prevent plastic from
ending up in the ocean and on the
streets
Richardson Gustav works for the project
which pays people to collect the garbage
which is then recycled it's a battle to
stop porta pants the capital of Haiti
from sinking in garbage the idea is to
fight pollution and poverty at once it
certainly brings hope but is this really
a feasible business model
all the trash that you see that's in the
canal basically come from up top where
the canal is wider basically this canal
was if you can look at all around is
wider than it seems it's just the fact
that the community brings tons of trucks
of dirt and just try to push the water
back I mean when I see it I see a change
I want to see what I can do to change it
what what does it take to change it you
know so that's really what I see I'm why
I see what I want to see what it takes
to change it when I look at this you
know because this is getting out of hand
Atlee nicknamed the steiner river this
is the tragic symbol of a city drowning
in trash the air smells rotten
there is no functioning garbage
collection system and Porto class which
has two and a half million inhabitants
most trash lands on the streets and in
the river the plastic bank wants to
prevent it from eventually ending up in
the ocean so it buys up plastic waste
and recycles it but it's early days for
the social plastic project there are
collection points across the city which
are funded by international firms
Richardson Gustav is in charge of portal
pass it's Saturday afternoon Gustav is
off to pay a visit to the collectors he
wants to remain in personal contact with
them the reason I'm really involved with
picking up the plastic is because the
collectors feel much more secure with
what they're doing when they see someone
in charge gets involved in making sure
that they're there okay
Richardson Gustav was born in Haiti but
grew up in the US he came back after
Haiti was devastated by hurricanes and
an earthquake he wants to help his
homeland to get back on its feet again
this is the Grizz River this is where
this is a where the water comes from the
mountain top up in th Onvia and it comes
down here over here as you can see where
the smokes are this is where all the
garbage get dumped from okay so what
I've built with these guys is sort of
like a cooperative also we have on this
side right here we have a few ladies
that collect the plastic from when the
dump truck come and dump the plastic so
first hand they get they grab all the
plastic materials out of the dump and
let all the other get get the marrow the
aluminum and stuff like that and they
have
leave the rest of the ones that can get
degraded on his free weekends Richardson
Gustav helps collect the plastic himself
this is motivating for the other
collectors for whom the money is not
always incentive enough the supply chain
has to be stable so that social plastic
becomes a profitable business model for
the future kesner Doris can does family
live right next to the garbage dump know
collecting garbage is profitable for him
especially as he doesn't have to
transport it himself he gets 455 Gord
some 6 euros for the garbage that's two
days wages but it's barely enough for a
family to live on door Oscar doesn't
want his children to look like their
father is a garbage collector a tailor
by training he makes all his daughter's
clothes himself he's been living here
for six years that's you do you not mind
living next to a garbage dump
I earn enough money to make a living we
just burned the rest of the garbage
those are my collected plastics right
there we have um we have something on
the other side I don't know the river is
kind of high so the crossing is kind of
but that doesn't stop them
they crossed the brown smelly waters
we're gonna go wash you know bastard
wobbler
it's hot dirty work
the smoke burns their eyes and leaves a
bitter taste in that throats some of the
garbage collectors complain they don't
want to be filmed they feel annoyed and
humiliated at the same time cares no
tries to placate them but he understands
their feeling of humiliation some of my
relatives know that I collect garbage
but not sure it could be a problem
that's why I only collect trash here and
that's why I always have a hood on
Louisville native there are 12 recycling
centers in Port apostle
everything is weighed up and registered
later it will be recycled and turned
into shampoo bottles for instance
plastic Bank has the support of
international companies they also
support the center financially it's
mainly girls and women who work here
Denis viola is the manager for the quad
a bouquet district she's been working
for the bank for some time now she talks
about the project's success as I see my
letters thanks to the plastic we have a
solar-powered system now so children
have light to study CT Soleil is one of
the poorest districts in Porto class the
importance of the centres here is clear
even philia as a mother of four children
she's been working for the plastic bank
for three years her entire family
collects garbage earning enough money to
pay the school fees which come to some
300 euros a year
they now have to collect even more
plastic because it's price on the market
has fallen
some 300 families live in this camp
Yvonne's family lives in this heart she
complains about the low price of plastic
at the moment I've got dreams and I
thought the plastic would help us it's
always got my husband doesn't have a job
so he also collects plastic we don't
have much money but it helps us to
collect plastic if I could get another
job I would at the moment we've only got
plastic so we collected asked what she
did before
Yvonne says she sold goods on the side
of the street she'd like to do that
again the price of plastic is dependent
on the price of natural gas when it's as
low as now it doesn't pay off to recycle
Richardson Gustav and his team also
visit schools to teach children about
the problem of plastic waste this is a
plastic bottle for water or juice what
do we do with it the children reply put
it in the garbage can kesner whiskas
daughter is in this class she's able to
go to school thanks to her father's job
with the plastic bank what do we do with
the plastic bottle to me this project
means life because it brings it brings
another it brings another light into our
community here brings an
the lighting to the families that we get
involved with it brings life into
everyone so to me this project means
life it means to live it means to dream
it means to love it means to everything
you know so that's why we put our
everything in it to try to get everyone
to get involved in this project to see
how we can get people to just recycle
the plastic and keep it from going into
the ocean keep it from going into our
streets
it's our streams and you know just try
to live to see a better world you know
the big goal is a clean ocean and a bit
of cash thanks to social plastic it's a
great idea that may take some time to
implement